épouse-moi t'invite dans notre cercle si
c'est toi qui souffle les bougies oh mon
dieu c'est une arnaque
il le méritait maman ton travail de se tenir
aux rideaux n'attaque pas les clients
et toi jeune femme surveille ta peau tu
es tellement bizarre qu'elle avait  beaucoup de problèmes
ce n'est rien de trop concerné quel est ce
nouvel accessoire pour l'esprit de travail pouvez-vous m'entendre
oui nous pouvons et nous pouvons vous voir qui
parlez-vous à Doris papa êtes-vous là
qui êtes-vous l'avez-vous vue écrire ceci
non parce que c'est polonais
portes qui ont fait ça je vais te montrer
tu es là
quelque chose se passe que nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre je suis inquiet pour ta copine
le monde des esprits est dangereux
qu'est ce que tu fais tu ne fais pas tu n'es pas
on a l'impression d'être étranglé  mort
quelque chose ne va pas avec Doris elle
vit quelque chose d'incroyable je crois
qu'elle canalise des pouvoirs nous ne
comprenons pas Doris
oui